hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the custom story at
cowards debt I'm starting to understand
that the coward in this story is
actually me I'm a terrible coward not
just because the monsters that I haven't
actually seen yet or trying to kill me
it's because then my character is trying
to get away from paying off his partner
who helped make him rich and if you are
exploiting the work of others and
passing it off as your own you
definitely deserve to go insane in your
own brain be shot in the head and then
spiraled down into chaos forever and
ever as you discover the agony of your
own insanity if that was poetic enough
for you I appreciate your appreciation
of my poetic nature because I in my
heart of hearts I know that I have no
idea where I'm going I'm actually going
in circles I believe I do not need to go
this way because I've already gone this
way this is where I got the candle to go
forward now it's still very very dark
and it's still very very hard for me to
get by I don't know if I like missed in
the beginning of the game there was
actually a lantern that I was supposed
to get a while ago or vines just a fool
who's trying to get by with nothing but
I've got an empty bottle and an
inclination that I need to go fill it
with a certain strange chemical
substance and then deliver that to
someone else so I'm gonna go back to the
first floor and explore the other
doorways that I saw because there might
be something there that I need yep ow
my brains I see it okay I didn't see it
before there was a key in the fire where
I put my hand and burned myself so I
need to fill this bottle up with water
which I could probably do in the
bathroom that I saw earlier where was
that I was wondering why there was a
point to this bathroom there must be
something in here that can help me fill
up this bottle yes scoop it over the
toilet get toilet water
who cares if it works it's gonna work
for me so that means I can pour this
over the fire get that key out of there
find out what door of the million that
are locked this key goes to I don't have
any tinderboxes I know that friend just
give me the key ah safe key so there
must be a safe behind some painting
somewhere
that I am then able Don Locke and I
probably overlooked it before I am very
good at overlooking simple details like
that it's not because I'm going through
this too quickly it's because my brain
isn't actively picking up on things 50%
of my brainpower right now is dedicated
to making commentary for you guys
although my commentary skills may be
lacking I try my hardest I'm gonna guess
that the safe is probably okey to the
office safe okay so there is definitely
a safe in one of these offices it may be
this one but then again it may not be so
I'll come back when I find it well this
wouldn't be an authentic 100% homegrown
markiplier video if I didn't get lost
[Applause]
what happened where am i what is going
on here wait a minute wait one goddamn
second here wait one goddamn second what
did I just trigger what this happened
who is you okay okay that's the bar down
there but I don't need to go down to the
bar I need to worry about what the hell
is happening right now what the hell was
that that the new monster or was that
just I'm beyond excited that was nothing
and I need to go this way now because
they need to go back to an office in the
beginning of the game and find where
that ding damn safe was so as soon as I
find a safe the sooner I can move on but
I'm guessing it's not gonna be that easy
you're not just gonna give it up to me I
got a coax it out of you I gotta buy you
dinner
I gotta get you a few drinks I got a su
I gotta make you swoon for me until you
give me that safe whatever the hell is
in this safe okay this is a bar this
would be a nice office to have if I was
a drunkard but then again I am not so
it's not good for me but maybe my
character is you never know what these
guys office
this looks off is he is there a safe in
here there's some sort of a safety thing
something to keep my valuables maybe
even my sanity I'm guessing maybe the
office was the place where the picture
of Alexander was but I don't recall
there being a safe in there and that
would be a lot of backtracking in my
opinion but then again maybe this is all
about backtracking what happened oh hi
baby
hello baby how are you doing over there
you look so good to me all sides not
inky blackness outside that must mean
it's a good day for you and me I'm all
right no I mean no now what are you
doing lady
Evangeline evangelion I am very sorry
the audio was there that was terrified I
didn't even get a good look at what it
was no no no no you do not put me all
the way back here you bastard you do not
put me all the way back here god damn it
oh my god was it not real I I don't know
about that good friend okay
good advice
okay so you're telling me that every
other good question that's what I want
to know oh man intense tips are good to
know thanks lady thanks for being the
informative voice of reason inside my
head now what the hell was that thing
that was obviously the new monster they
created and it was way faster nothing
that I ever expected out of amnesia holy
crap that thing was fast it was this
creepy crawly because it was low to the
ground I did not like it so anyway
there's got to be a way to get to the
office now those doors are both locked
they think good golly Miss Molly that
was okay so that's why this game is
utterly terrifying by some accounts and
I don't I have no idea what I need to do
now so I need to get to the office
there's got to be a safe somewhere
around here buying a painting somewhere
in the original area but then again my
guess was before I got completely
disoriented by what just happened was
that there may have been a safe in this
room I don't know if I ever actually
tried behind alexander's face yeah but
then maybe maybe not maybe I'm gone to
something maybe I'm not hello exactly
examiner you're very close to my head I
don't did not like that very much by the
way don't know if you picked up on that
but I was not having a fun time so now
what I need to do is I guess I need to
go back until I find an office I heard
something originally behind that door in
the last episode so I'm assuming that
there might be something there again
I've just gotta gotten used to the
darkness by now although maybe I
shouldn't oh maybe oh this was a safe
oh that was a safe I didn't know does a
safe have to make such creepy sounds and
invoke a piano I no idea that was
actually a safe I never even thought
about that that never crossed my mind
can I get a lantern oh oh that's just
chemical tiny box Tim are you in here I
could really use your company right now
things are not going very well for me I
don't know if you knew this but I miss
you with all my heart tiny bugs Tim I
love you you will always be in my heart
of hearts even in the darkest times so
there's nothing else in here besides
that chemical and now I need to go back
the way I came and confront that monster
goo goo the monster Magoo goo you gotta
kill me maybe but then again wasn't
there a hole in the wall over here okay
okay I can just open it it is dark in
there it would be a really bad time for
a monster Mugu goo jump out of there
there's something I need to put in here
oh no okay those are these chemicals I
knew this in the back of my head I just
never said it these chemicals are gonna
be joined together to create the fuel
cell and then I'm gonna take it out of
the machine and put it in that machine
to hopefully go up to the third floor
and then I never ever ever ever ever
ever ever ever ever ever have to meet up
with that douche McGee again why is it
so dark in here oh it is so dark so dark
why is it - there's literally pitch
blackness I do not like that I'm not
getting used to the darkness oh hello
mr. piano man good to see you again
hello mr. photograph lady oh this is the
room where the guy got me okay I got it
is there any more messages for you lady
you want to see key arm oh yeah Elmo
dear told over all my neighbor totoro no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no what the hell is that
who's plucking on the heartstrings of
terror
seriously though was that the calling
card to that thingamabob er because I do
not want to meet him again that is like
God it reminds me of the first time when
I'm in the moves man or the Thing Thing
or mister face you know thank you Oh God
I'm like you know normally I want to
like see things but I have every reason
to never ever ever want to see that
thing it reminds me of the the thing
from SCP containment breach the uh the
thing if you look at the face you die
die die you die die you don't just die
you die three times over in very
horrible way but it reminds me of that
thing when it's crawling on the ground
superfast at you and I do not like it
okay so I should be able to make a
straight shot up to the place where I
need to go I find myself going very
slowly through this area to sit in total
apprehension of what's in front of me
Joyce some tells me I made a mistake
some tells me I'm a dumb dumb dumb dumb
yeoman hello hi a monster in here are
you gonna cry are you gonna cry for me
please don't cry for me don't cry for my
gravy that you're about to make for me
oh I really do find myself creeping
through this area and remind me of the
first time when I was also when I was in
the oh god what was it it was the
dungeon area the jail cells of the
original game amnesia I find miss I
found myself going through those so
slowly because it was just pitch
blackness I swear it's darker than it
was before I am NOT crazy in that regard
it is actually darker so anyway I think
it was through here
oh okay cool great I'm glad that
happened I'm glad I'm glad that happened
I'm real glad thank you God
[ __ ] you man Jesus Oh God
like I said the maker of this mod is
very good no no no you ain't gonna do
nothing do me huh oh yeah you locked
behind that door he's never gonna get me
never never never never
we're gonna give me up never get get me
dead never kill me dead and kill me no
no no not gonna look oh look what's
there what is it what is it what is it
what is it what is it
I can't see what it is what is it what
is it what is it is it a head to the
bottle what do I need to look at I'm
turpentine it okay you're saying I need
a turpentine to get away from the
monster what huh what why what did I do
okay good I'm coughing blood down I'm
coughing blood to back onto my own face
why why are you doing this to me why am
i doing this to me why am me do this to
me me passing out on the floor good sign
the i am i dying what is going on
that's another thing that I like about
horror games especially when they have a
sense of mystery about Oh killed myself
in this room
oh oh okay my wrist hurts
to suffer from my damnable sin which was
okay it doesn't I didn't kill my wife
okay I have a guess did I do
is it to do with y'all I cannot give you
the answers John
okay I think I know I ever I have
actually a solid guess of what happened
total seriousness what I think happened
is gingham came to the house finally and
tried to kill me but my wife Evangeline
stepped in the way died I was extremely
sad and it was my fault because I never
told anyone and I didn't resolve it I
let my greed get the best of me and
therefore I am punished for it because
my wife totally innocent died because of
my actions
kachunk and I closed all K step away
from the spinning doodad goody goody
gumdrops you know no so much detail put
into a machine for pigs in terms of just
like the random stuff that was happening
along there okay so I got an electric
fuse what does that mean it's not a fuel
cell do I still put it in the machine
down there okey-dokey so I'm going out
now wait what was it oh yeah downer so I
take this fuel cell and then I go about
my business and do what exactly this
game keeps me guessing because I have no
goddamn idea when the scares are gonna
come which is good I suppose so I have
this fuel cell or not a fuel cell I have
an electric cell no not that way it's
not where I want to go that's not where
I want to go either this is the wrong
way so I need to back no no no you stay
I am NOT okay with this game I'm not
okay with this you are being a sassy
[ __ ] and I wanna go home
the clues is Durer buying me all polite
thank you for clicking shut gonna go
this way I know the game was just giving
me a shortcut back and I should be more
appreciative of its actions but somehow
I wanted to die and douchey death so let
me what the wait a minute
this is way I wouldn't know this doesn't
feel right where am I going I thought no
no no no no no no no I made a wrong turn
somewhere that's locked wait a minute no
no no no oh
we ended up on the other side of the
chasm there no wait what oh that's all
right wait wait a minute no my I okay
there we go that's what I thought I was
utterly confused not early turned around
there I had no idea which way I was
going guys game is done
no seriously this game is honestly one
of the scariest custom stories I've ever
played it was such a progressive intro
to the like the the terror aspect of it
which like most games is like horror and
it need not be like that it never need
be like that it needs to be elegant as
elegant as it is mysterious in its
execution and for this I love this one
stuck in my own mind I was right when I
said I was in my own mind but maybe not
even in my own mind I'm actually dead at
least that's what I'm led to believe
perhaps I am not dead perhaps death is
only the beginning of my torment was
this open before yeah it was so I need
to take this electric fuse and put it in
the machine oh that I saw before I came
to this area and I dunno I don't know
why but I'm at I'm having extreme
amounts of trouble remembering where
I've been oh this is nice again I'm glad
that this got fixed up Guillermo did you
do this
Guillermo dario or me over this is not
pitch black anymore okay I'm over that
but there is a violin in this chair was
this always here don't know who's that
my wife's a throw it up against the wall
who cares I do maybe I don't
maybe I'm an [ __ ] maybe I'm just a
douche ooh killed now I have maybe he
wasn't gear about to kill my wife maybe
I killed my wife in preparation of
trying to meet with Guillermo the demon
that I made up in my mind because I was
paranoid that he was trying to kill me
and I ended up doing it what's that wait
a minute no no no no no we just know
where God I keep getting turned around
no oh there we go okay here we go got it
got it got it
I got it everybody calm down
I have it all under control well I get
the heebie-jeebies all over the place
the heebie-jeebies has scientifically
quantifiable are these scaredy weirdies
but I know more amplified so is that now
good it wasn't a fuel-cell like you said
it was what what happened why does all
get out this happened before but I'm
just wondering if it was meant to be
like this okay I need to fix this BRB
all right so I'm back and still
recording sorry about that it's just uh
I think the methodology of which I'm
monitoring my own voice is causing some
sound issues but it shouldn't be a
problem from here on out so let's see
where this third floor really goes wait
a minute I'm going down I need to go to
the third floor is the third floor down
I think I think there may be some
confusion in the insanity inside my mind
I need to okay never mind we're in a
crazy world where up is down and left is
right and but certain not nice so where
are we going
am I gonna see a machine for pigs for me
oh good I like the way the door just
dissolves I don't think I'm gonna step
into that darkness
if you don't mind I'd rather do anything
but that but here I go because I'm brave
for you guys viewing at home I will okay
bye have fun
I'll just be down here you come get me
whenever you're ready oh god I remember
one particular comment that said that
the basement was not a fun place Sarah
okay I'm just having to be a tiny box
around here who've anyone seen a tiny
box his name is Tim and I love him okay
moving for ward
moving forward very slowly okay I don't
like this I'm just gonna say that right
now I do not like to play very much at
all mr. Todd this is like the creepiest
I've ever seen amnesia for a long time
what is that sound
it sounds like boxes moving around that
I'm not sure someone there is anybody
there
anybody know is there the skittering of
a cockroaches that the rapid approach
I'm a monster that I need to run away
from I'm going to die down here
I literally am going to die down here
okay so there's a box there push that
down nothing there so I just need to go
okay I may have just screwed myself over
because I need to get all the boxes out
so that I can open this closet which
probably has a monster I'm just gonna
say why else would I need to unbury and
unleash something that is deep down in
this basement why else would I be here
why else there's no other reason I do
not see tiny bugs this is a good idea
this is a good idea
hello if you're evil you'd tell me right
okay I was like ever
I can use it literally not cool
this is just about hood high statue I
didn't see you till just now
should I throw my giant sledgehammer and
your face okay well that was
anticlimactic so what am I supposed to
do shut up Subway's bring in my hair
your evil will not work here I am a man
of many convictions I can't even open
that I don't even know why I'm trying to
be quiet I just look like it's so quiet
in there shut up
Shh roaches the monster will hear you oh
god I'm so tense right now
no thank you
not tough you're it oh I see okay
don't know if I did that but just gonna
move on I see what I need this for oh
that's the way too damn loud tiny no
tiny No
okay okay room of warm happiness or room
of warm death eNOS okay okay
Oh God huh that was like the slowest
I've ever gone through any game ever in
the history of ever
master bedroom key where the hell was
the master bedroom was over here I can't
see there's some over here oh I see
that's like that was uh back to the way
I was um in the beginning there was a
way to look through here this is where I
was looking through original is there
something any no okay
place to hide maybe okay so dark so dark
so dark no yes
I don't know so dark can't see anything
hello hello why are you facing me no you
don't dare you [ __ ] okay okay okay okay
I'm just gonna go I'm just gonna go just
go
I'm just gonna go I'm just gonna go no
one's gonna bother me nothing's gonna
hurt me I'm just gonna go everything's
fine everything's totally cool
everything's totally cool happy place Oh
nay
oh he's right outside maybe he's not no
no okay maybe you didn't get anywhere
near me
maybe he's absolutely nowhere I need to
go out and check
I don't wanna for you guys I'd do
anything right am I supposed to do what
am I supposed to do what am I supposed
to do I can't see anything
okay no no it was the most terrifying
noise I've ever heard and you there are
you in the darkness what are you getting
ready no I need to do what do we do oh
god what do I do
what sir sir I got a chair have it sir
having to use its arid forever hey Mel
the need to use a turn Robert I lose a
legitimately figures my only defense
between me in that [ __ ] are you gonna
do to me what are you gonna do to me
when you find me oh no likey that
where am i where am i oh oh it was
Moseley kill me Oh again with the
supposed to kill meanness you son of a
[ __ ] okay right yeah to the truth good
right and go to the third floor I know
okay I already know why I'm here I guess
my reason maybe you don't need to
destroy me anyway this episode would
probably the most scariest the most the
scariest episode mmm nietzsche i've ever
recorded and that is awesome that this
game can still scare me and surprise me
and that the developer is able to
deliver such amazing scares that was
awesome although i felt like i was the
instrument of my own destruction there
because i brawl agentive run away so
effectively from it i'm very good at
doing that but either way hope you're
still enjoying this custom story so
thank you all so much for watching
remember has a whole bunch more in the
description if you want to check out my
older custom stories thanks again
everybody and as always I will see you
in the next video by
[Applause]
[Music]